he warned us that something was coming  if there is ever an end in this forever  war it will be because of you and your  strong right hand where the line in the  sand we fight against the forces of  darkness this is the we're expecting a  sign that says secret headquarters oh I  need some ID love oh are you serious you  made me a damn weapon I just wanted to  help you become the best you  [Applause]  some dads get their kids Legos to be  saved in the world of silence  does it do anything special yeah  it smashes things real good  [Music]  you are mankind's best and only hope I  thought we were supposed to be fighting  monsters not working with  you call it monster pal you look lemare  recently he's an ass sorry  he's arrived just in time  [Music]  you